my next guest believes the ongoing
impeachment charade was never about
removing President Trump from office
instead it was designed as a tool to
hurt Republican senators in blue and
purple states this is a guy that has
never lost the case as a prosecutor and
is like pretty smart guys also are you
now back officially as the Fox News
contributor did we put the camera back
where it's supposed to be trey Gowdy is
with us everything's great and I'm
thrilled about counselor I didn't ask if
everything's great did they take care of
you and Reese EIN you because I'm
fighting for trey Gowdy to be a Fox News
contributor
I'll do it publicly yes sir they've been
fantastic they've been great thank you
they've been great you gave a lot of
great statements woo I know this is your
wheelhouse tell us why this is so
corrupt well I mean let's skip over the
process the the process the three-month
long inquiry investigation was laughable
but they voted that's the House's
prerogative they voted not a single
Republican went along with them in fact
they they didn't even keep all the
Democrats but the House exercised its
prerogative and they impeach the
president
there is no mathematical way he's ever
going to be convicted and they know that
so their goal cannot be to remove Donald
Trump from office it is to neuter his
second term I think he's going to win in
November to neuter that second term by
targeting the quarry gardeners and the
and the martha mcsally's and the thom
tillis and the susan collins and Joanie
arts because if Trump wins and he
doesn't have the Senate then he's not
going to get any judicial vacancies
filled he's not going to replace a
Supreme Court justice if he or she
retires he's not going to get the farm
policy once he's not going to get the
cabinet he wants so I never thought this
was about removing Donald Trump because
they're not going to do it it's about
putting Cory Gardner and a really tough
series of votes so he has to defend them
in November of this fall I think you're
right everything is through the prism of
politics especially there are 299 days
to go until the American people they get
to be make the final decision it's up to
them and they can shock the world again
and I hope trey Gowdy that in fact that
that happens let me ask you this
question and it's a legal one so
constitutionally it's
the sole role of the House of
Representatives to impeach it is the
sole role of the Senate to put the trial
on we have a role for the Chief Justice
of the Supreme Court he presides now the
house managers will present their case
now they're trying to have a redo and
get the Senate to do the job that they
couldn't do in the house what is your
reaction what would you tell Republican
senators tonight the same thing I told
them in the op-ed you know it's Adam
shifts job if he thinks the testimony of
John Bolton is so indispensable then he
should have subpoenaed him and the same
with Mick Mulvaney and Mike Pompeo and
Rudy Giuliani the Senate's job is to
deliberate it is not to investigate and
then deliberate because if that were
true we wouldn't need the house shift
was in such a hurry I mean keep in mind
Sean all your viewers have to go to
court if they have a disagreement with a
fellow citizen House Republicans had to
go to court to get documents and fast
and furious we had to go fight Adam
Schiff in court to find out who funded
the dossier so we all know how to get to
the courthouse Schiff didn't want to go
to court he wants to send it to call the
very witnesses that he didn't have the
courage to call himself and that's not
their job the good news is the senators
that I talked to on a regular basis
under the leadership of Mitch McConnell
are not falling for Nancy Pelosi's trick
she can send them and they'll do what
they want but they are not moved by this
three-week pause that she's engaged in
all right trey Gowdy oh wait welcome
back I was gonna go to bat for you
tonight okay I don't have to that's good